[Musique]
une péniche contenant un produit toxique
a commencé à couler après avoir heurté
un pont lundi 20 février vers 18h
l'incidence s'est déroulée à hauteur de
Triel-sur-Seine la barge transportait du
nitrate de calcium un produit utilisé
dans le cadre du traitement des eaux
usées selon le service public de
l'assainissement francilien
incompartiment a été endommagé et s'est
déversé en faible quantité dans la scène
le pompage du produit a été activé dès
hier soir des prélèvements sont
actuellement effectués pour s'assurer de
l'absence d'impact sur le milieu naturel
à ce stade il n'est pas redouté d'effet
sur la qualité de la scène la barge à
quant à elle était remarquée et mise à
quai suite aux violences séismes qui ont
récemment frappé la Turquie et la Syrie
et qui ont causé un lourd bilan matériel
et humain le département des Yvelines a
choisi de se mobiliser il a voté une
aide d'urgence de 100.000 euros à l'ONG
répond aux besoins des populations en
menant des opérations de secours et de
distribution dans les zones touchées
halte aux petits comédiens en herbe la
série Sam recherche de une jeune
figurant yvelinois la production
recherche 40 enfants entre 6 et 14 ans
pour sa septième saison le tournage aura
lieu à mille mots entre les 7 avril et
le 6 mai et se déroulera sur un maximum
de 3 demi-journées la rémunération brute
sera de 94 euros par journée de tournage
plus d'informations sur le site internet
casse prod.com la RATP lance une
importante campagne de recrutement dans
la perspective de la Coupe du monde de
rugby 2023 et des Jeux Olympiques 2024
la compagnie annonce que 6600 postes
sont à pourvoir tout au long de l'année
un record pour le transporteur
francilien plus de la moitié des
contrats seront en CDI et concerneront
en majorité le recrutement de
conducteurs de bus depuis sa création en
février 2022 l'accélérateur d'entreprise
créée par hectare et l'incubateur HEC
Paris accompagne déjà 42 startups du
secteur agricole et alimentaire dans
leur développement nous voter pour
l'établissement les coopérations
agricoles axéréales Val de Gascogne
eurodem natop et MC2 ont choisi
d'officialiser un partenariat proposer
de solutions accessibles aux
agriculteurs elles vont faire partie des
jurys de sélection des futurs promotions
de start-up
[Musique]